foreign
my name is Sarah I'm currently residing
in Oxford England
increasingly my default state is
becoming more so the skies falling
unless Everything is Awesome with
inflation volatile markets looming
recession resource scarcity and climate
change it's all overwhelming and
freaking me out
can you guys give practical methodical
steps that will help me get through the
inevitable zombie apocalypse
is there real hope for regular folks
what should we invest in how should we
prepare
what should we consider when making
decisions with regards to the Future
now Sarah the sky isn't falling you're
falling and there's nothing to hold on
to and as soon as I realized this that
everyone when they're born is sort of
pushed out of an airplane and they're
plummeting toward their death yeah and
we try to hold on to things that we see
in the air along the way I'm gonna hold
on to this house or this car or this
career thinking it's going to Stave off
the inevitable right yeah now of course
it seems to me like Sarah has been
watching a lot of news and news is
really good at aggregating your eyeballs
onto catastrophes that are far away from
you and often have very little or no
influence on your life they have no
direct effect on your life quite often
there are exceptions to that obviously
but most of the things that are
propagated by any news media is
propagated in order to get our attention
so they can sell us advertisements it's
the reason we say advertisements suck on
this podcast all of the cancel culture
and political climate and and the
dysfunction is really a byproduct either
directly or indirectly of advertising
culture because censorship is not the
corporations really censoring us it's
the corporations who are advertising on
these platforms that are censoring us
and so we have to be really careful and
understand the true motives of any media
outlet and it's not that they're evil or
bad they're there to sell you products
and services from other major
corporations and it's not necessarily
aligned with your interests or your
values now Wendy in the book you talk
about rabbit holes versus wrecking balls
versus trench warfare yeah I thought
that was a perfect sort of Keyhole look
into
Sarah's question yeah
um
indeed uh you know one rabbit holes
wrecking balls trench warfare are all of
the negative vicious the patterns of
negative Vicious Cycles that happen when
we either or and Sarah first of all I
want to empathize it feels like the
world is a little chaotic and you're not
alone
and uh we have to take action to be able
to navigate those spaces on our own what
struck me as Sarah was asking this
question was this tension between the
magnitude of our problems and what feels
like the potential for us to actually
navigate those problems and this false
trade-off between big changes and small
actions it's a real false trade-off I
hear this all the time when we talk
about change big change movements
possibilities which is that how can my
you know we need massive systemic change
or do we need individual hearts and
minds and actions to change things well
both we need both and if we get so
caught up in the large magnitude we go
down this rabbit hole that nothing is
possible and then we get stuck that's
the rabbit hole we go down one side of a
possibility and we get stuck
one way to navigate that big change is
to start with the small actions right
the Margaret made us uh committed
thoughtful set of citizens to make
change and start small changing hearts
and minds and Sarah for us for us
individuals it means starting to take
action on some of these things that
leads to collectively the bigger shift
but if we just stand there and do
nothing we get nowhere yeah no I yeah I
love that I uh I like what you talked
about how we're all falling to our
deaths slowly but you know like when I
when I look at it that way
it's a relief in the sense that
um no matter what's happening around me
it's like it helps me appreciate like
well here I am in this moment yeah and
how lucky am I to like have this
experience like I don't look at the
universe revolving around me I mean
maybe I do in some aspects I think we're
all a little solipsistic to a certain
degree but different podcasts uh we can
talk about that but instead of me
looking at it like oh the universe
revolves around me it's more about like
oh like this is the universe's existence
and I am so lucky to have this little
place in it and so from that perspective
yeah I don't have these grandiose plans
to change the world I'm open to doing
that like I'd love to change the world
but like that's not my expectation my
expectation or maybe
um a better way to say it is my standard
is like I'm gonna do what I can with Who
I Am with the resources that I have and
I'm gonna try and you know give as much
as I can and that's that's who I am in
general I was we were having a
conversation yesterday I was talking
about how when I interact with someone
um yeah I'm trying to give them
something I'm trying to like you know
maybe make their day a little better or
you make them a little happier or
whatever and what did you say to me Josh
you said um
was it Kapil goop that you're like oh
you know you're like this is what I love
about Kapil Gupta he's not trying to
give you anything he's just trying to
exist yeah he's not trying to change
your mind he's not trying to help anyone
either yeah we have a question about
help later that I think uh will
illuminate this quite a bit I I've
realized that one of the most dangerous
people in the world is the helper a
helper I wrote an essay about this a
couple years ago but a helper will take
a fish out of the ocean to keep it from
drowning or to take an eagle out of the
sky to prevent it I'm just helping you
so you don't fall right and there's a
difference between help and support sure
I think what we do with this podcast is
we support people in their healing yeah
they're healing their relationship with
stuff feeling their relationship with
people here healing their relationship
with mental clutter psychological
clutter emotional clutter we
feel compelled to help them but to help
them is to try to change them in a way
instead of trying to change them I can
be a support beam and if you need to
lean against me you can and so I can be
that support structure for anyone else
without needing to go out and force the
change onto them yeah I yeah I I get
that and I think that's a great
um it's a great way to look at it so
um yeah I'm trying to support people and
that is that's just my my being like
that's just I if I didn't do that I
wouldn't be being genuine so is that
going to change the world no but can I
you know get a cup of coffee and be like
hey how's your day going and here in La
they're looking at me like
what do you need like you don't care
about my day and I'm like oh okay
um I just you know want a small coffee
um but seriously like how's your day
going and then they're like oh like
maybe this maybe this guy actually does
care and I can create these little
meaningful interactions on a day-to-day
basis yeah it's not gonna like change
the world it may not even send out a
ripple yeah but I mean if everyone could
at least take that radical uh ownership
of their day-to-day actions like that is
really where those those big changes are
gonna take effect it's it's unfortunate
that like
I don't I mean it's in America and I'm
sure it's in other countries too but we
have this like delusion that if we vote
for the right person
um not just president but let's just say
on a local level we have this delusion
that all of a sudden our lives are going
to be radically different and that's
just not the case like the president
isn't going to clean up our room and do
our laundry for us uh you know the the
congressman or the state senator that we
vote for uh they're not going to come in
mow your lawn like we have to do these
things they're not going to be nice for
you they can't do it for you and uh yeah
I think taking that radical ownership
that's the only thing that we can take
responsibility for
um and yeah every all the other problems
that she's mentioning those are going to
be there whether or not we take that
radical ownership I love what you said
about the news like stop looking at the
news that would be my number one thing
is stop looking at the news because I do
it to myself I'm speaking from uh my own
personal experience where when I find
that like oh my goodness like we're all
gonna we're either gonna die because the
world's going to catch fire from global
warming or from nuclear warfare and
that's stressful and when I catch myself
thinking that I'm like where's this
coming from oh it's the uh infotainment
that I'm taking in and I I have to catch
myself and and stay away from away from
from uh for a little bit so yes Sarah um
that would be step number one I would
say stop looking at the news so much and
um you know start looking at what you
can do day to day it's probably a good
good first step did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free